un bon soir caleb mopar merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france on
referme les écoles à new york on imagine
que c'est un petit séisme dans la ville
est ce qu'on s'y attendait ce jour il y
a vraiment un sentiment de
démoralisation aux états unis les gens
ressens de la frustration envers le
gouvernement envers ses réactions
il ya beaucoup de frustration liée à
l'état de l'économie
donc les gens n'accueille pas la
nouvelle de bon coeur qu'il considère
que ce nouveau confinement est
nécessaire ou pas on imagine que c'est
une décision qui n'a pas été prise au
hasard vous pouvez nous en expliquer les
raisons précises beaucoup de cas de
contamination chez les enfants c'est
bien ça les enfants ne seront plus à la
maison étudieront à nouveau depuis chez
eux ce qui représente un effort
supplémentaire pour de nombreuses
familles et pourrait causer des
difficultés
le système éducatif américain est une
fois de plus à l'épreuve au cours des
derniers mois il ya eu beaucoup
d'enseignement à distance dans beaucoup
d'écoles et on s'est donc ajuster au
niveau des écoles pour que cela continue
à fonctionner mais effectivement il ya
de la frustration de la part des parents
qui doivent travailler de la part des
enseignants et d'autres
la situation est mauvaise pour le pays
c'est certains l'annoncent d'un futur
vaccin par faïza réer moderna qu'elle me
pince que c'est de nature à remettre du
baume au coeur chez ces américains que
vous nous décrivez comme les français
d'ailleurs très déprimé
avec ces restrictions et notamment la
fermeture des écoles à new york est ce
que il ya cette lueur d'espoir à
laquelle on croit désormais c'est assez
intéressant le débat autour des vaccins
va à l'encontre des débats autour de la
vaccination habituellement les
démocrates ont tendance à accuser les
conservateurs les partisans de donald
trump d'être des complotistes anti
vaccins et de mettre en danger la santé
publique
aujourd'hui il semblerait que ce sont
les démocrates qui remettent ce vaccin
en question qui disent que peut-être
donald trump a accéléré le processus de
vaccination pour des raisons politiques
ce sont les républicains qui font part
de leur confiance en le président et
sont prêts à se faire vacciner
ce sont donc les démocrates qui
remettent en question le vaccin
l'administration donc c'est vraiment le
monde à l'envers et cela montre qu'il ya
un peu d'hypocrisie dans cette situation
si le complot est à votre profit alors
vous l'accepter comme un fait donc ses
incohérences reflète la façon dont les
élections présidentielles ce sont des
relais l'adoption des théories de fraude
ou le fait de nous la met des personnes
telles que la russie est ce qui rend ces
accusations de fraude acceptable ou
d'autres personnes qui les rend non
acceptable vous parliez de donald trump
le même temps un autre homme qui est
accusé par un joe biden de risque et de
nombreux morts
parce qu ils ne coopèrent pas justement
avec les démocrates sur cette crise du
coronavirus c'est très clair il n'y a
pas d' approche unifiée dans le pays
pour la gestion de la pandémie il ya un
fossé entre les plus acteurs principaux
certaines personnes pensent qu un
confinement irait en leur sens par
exemple les grands géants de
l'informatique
wal mart amazon aimerait se servir de ce
confinement pour assurer leur monopole
pour les petits commerces les boutiques
home depot par exemple dont les
propriétaires sont des soutiens de
donald trump pour les sociétés les
entreprises hydro fracturation qui
souffrent beaucoup des prix très bas de
l'essence il est très important de
réouvrir l'économie très rapidement donc
les grands monopoles sont en faveur du
confinement et les petits commerces
souhaiterait une réouverture très rapide
donc du fait de cette division il n'y a
pas d' approche unifiée pour la gestion
de la pandémie
chaque état décide des restrictions et
des politiques à mettre en place
joe byden accuse the donald trump blâme
donald trump pour le manque d'unité dans
les réponses à la crise l'administration
byden pourrait introduire une approche
plus unifiée mais certaines certains
acteurs résisteront car ils penseront
que cela va favoriser
les grandes entreprises les géants de la
tech les deux côtés sont donc biaisé
quant à la gestion de la pandémie les
élites sont divisés et veulent que la
pandémie soient gérées afin de leur être
favorable merci beaucoup cas nettement
pas un correspondant d'arte et aux etats
unis d'avoir été avec nous